[Music]
cheyenne is with us in arizona hi
cheyenne welcome to the ramsay show
hi rachel and dave thank you for having
me sure what's up i have a question i'm
55 a widow i'm out of debt and i have
about four hundred thousand dollars just
sitting in the bank
i am one of those um investment
resistant people
i feel like it's out of my control
i have
did a deep dive into trying to invest
and talk to two different people who
were financial people and got very deep
in what they were recommending to me
but as i was
researching it there'd be something
there that i just didn't want to invest
in a mcdonald's or a pepsi or some kind
of chemical farming or things like that
and i
so
you know i've downsized my lifestyle i
i i've been a medical person for 30
years so i'm semi retired i could go
back tomorrow and do that income's not a
problem
i just would like to know
what your opinion is someone like me if
it's what you think oh my goodness it's
not growing
i have a friend that just lost 80 000 in
the last month a whole year of her
income based on the market where she has
the money and that just feels so out of
control for me to put it somewhere where
i have no control
your friend was investing in some kind
of high risk something to lose eighty
thousand dollars in one month
or or she has two million dollars
invested one of the two which is it
okay
well i don't know the person
something to do with their work
okay see that was a high risk single
stock investment and so that's not so
the market represents the stock market
represents everything from ultra high
risk scary crazy stuff down to things
that are just plain boring and so um
when someone says they lost money in the
market it can mean that they were
virtually gambling in las vegas or it
can mean
that they you know that they just panic
every time that the needle moves a
little bit um so but you don't you don't
have a stomach for it is what you're
saying
and you can't i don't have the stomach
for it and you've attempted to uh gain
enough knowledge to get some peace and
it hasn't worked so
um but you can't leave uh 400 000
sitting at one percent either you that's
why you called agreed
uh yes
yeah i mean because you're making
nothing
so what about buying some real estate
that creates some income
well i did that two i did two houses and
turned them in during covid but of
course it was coved and so everything
was twice as much and the help was
so i mean i didn't lose but i didn't it
certainly wouldn't show
it wouldn't have been worth it in other
words so that's because if you continue
to jump in and out of things you're
always going to lose money
you got to ride the wave out not
necessarily redoing a property but just
buying one renting it out and having
that passive income if you had a forty
thousand dollar property that i mean
four hundred thousand dollar property
that you simple piece of you know nice
house that someone rented for three or
four thousand dollars a month
uh you'd be making a whole lot more than
you would on the bank
true uh it's something i don't enjoy
i've had many years of it and and not
the best claim not the best years of it
so cheyenne i have a question
yeah you you presented two problems with
investing one it was companies that you
just didn't agree with morally you
mentioned like pepsi or mcdonald right
i'm guessing you just don't agree with
them as companies and the fear that
you're gonna lose money which is greater
do you feel like which which part of it
makes it like
oh
you know i guess in one sense i'm i want
to put my money where my heart is you
know and have it
manifest something good on the on the
earth
okay what would that be
no i don't know i've been trying to
search and find it
maybe there's some good funds
where people are
christ-centered you know
you don't find out at the top that
they're
moving against
mankind i'd like to see i'd like to
invest in something that means maybe
food i don't know
well there's um
number one when you're dealing with a
mutual fund
you're dealing with
90 to 200 different companies inside of
a mutual fund
and um
at any given time one of those companies
could have some kind of a business
practice
disclosed or undisclosed that somebody
doesn't agree with okay now you're not
giving them money when you buy their
stock okay if you buy
stock in a company from me
you gave me the money
now you are benefiting when they make a
profit and the stock goes up in value
uh you are benefiting from their actions
that you don't agree with and so that
part i do understand but if there's 90
to 200 and one half of one of the
companies is doing something wrong
that's kind of like you shopping at a
grocery store that also sells stuff you
don't agree with but you bought the
stuff you do agree with there
you really can't find any you really
can't find something that's a hundred
percent pure in this world this side of
heaven um if now i will tell you one
thing to investigate there is a group
out of atlanta called the timothy fund
the timothy fund
and it is a mutual fund and um
their goal is to invest in companies
that to avoid investing in companies
that engage in something anything they
consider to be non-christian and so for
instance they don't invest in any
tobacco companies or
uh alcohol companies um
they might invest in a chemical company
you don't agree with based on what
you're saying i don't know but um but
yeah the timothy fund is actually done
it's a it's a moral based fund a
christian based idea
um and they've done very well they've
got a good long-term track record uh you
might investigate them and learn about
them i don't have i'm not associated
with them in any way um i don't have any
money in there and i'm not because i'm
against them uh it's just not the prop
process i have used to do analysis for
my
my fund picks but um i've been aware of
them for over a decade and they've got
the main central fund has probably got a
now it's probably got a 20-year track
record and it's it's beating the market
and uh
so and i would say too shy and if you if
you decide to step into something
because you're wanting to make more than
just one percent you don't have to just
do all five hundred thousand like do
fifty thousand for a year and see how
that feels and maybe you take another
hundred thousand right like you can kind
of
move your way into this um but for your
benefit long term
uh for you to even be generous on the
other end to be able to give some money
away to things that you really do care
about um
making that money and that's part of
that i appreciate your pure heart but
that bank is paying you one percent i'll
guarantee you they're engaged in things
you don't like
i can just a hundred percent guarantee
that
so there's not a place you can hide
from that no i'll just promise you
they're
they're donating the things you don't
agree with i can promise you they are